good evening my name is Lukas Swenson
I'm from Howard Lake Minnesota I'm
setting political economy and German
here at Hillsdale I'm a sophomore and
today I have the pleasure of introducing
Arthur Herman who's a senior fellow at
the Hudson Institute he is a professor
he has been a professor of history at
Georgetown University Catholic
University George Mason University and
the University of the South he writes
regularly for a commentary foreign
policy the American interest mosaic nici
Asian review and the Wall Street Journal
he is the author of several books
including Gandhi and Churchill the epic
rivalry that destroyed an empire and
forged our age which was a finalist for
the Pulitzer Prize in 2009 Douglas
MacArthur American warrior and the
forthcoming 1917 Lenin Wilson and the
birth of the New World Disorder please
join me in welcoming dr. art there
[Applause]
[Music]
how are you it's good to see you I
should say welcome to Hillsdale College
but a lot of you are already here you
another place this is actually my first
visit I've done I've spoken had the
pleasure and the privilege of speaking
Hillsdale College cruises twice which
I've enjoyed very much
and so when Larry Arne said we want you
to come and speak to our our Center on
constructive alternatives about part of
the subject 1/2 of your new book 19-7
his what lenin hath wrought over the
last 100 years in 1917 of course is the
watershed date when he becomes a world
historical figure and i also want to
talk about Lenin's legacy and I want to
be sure to save some time to talk about
that what I want to do in the first part
of my lecture however is to dispel some
myths about Lenin myths which were very
prevalent when I went to college which
was shortly after the Civil War
myths that were very prevalent and are
still very prevalent in our colleges
universities today I want to talk to you
about that and which I think have kind
of glossed over who Lenin really was and
what his real legacy was right up until
today three myths I wanted to spell the
first is that the the legend that he is
the father of the Russian Revolution as
you're going to find out he's not he
cashes in on the Russian Revolution but
he's not the father ever the real
revolution takes place when these
hundreds hundreds of miles away from the
events and even ignorant of what happens
until it tell it's over the second myth
I'm going to dispel is that Lenin was a
disciple of Karl Marx and of Marxism
yeah I know I just saw some faces fall
including by leading scholars in it but
I'm going to explain that too that Lenin
comes from a very different world in a
very different way of understanding how
human history works and what takes place
and that has a huge impact on the legacy
is going to have later on the third myth
I'm going to dispel is the myth that
Lenin was better than his successors
that in other words that he was really a
good guy who if it hadn't been for a
series of strokes that debilitating him
in 1923 and then finally killed him in
January 1924 that that the direction he
would have taken the Soviet Union and
communism would have been very different
from that of Joseph Stalin and that his
and that if he had lived that the legacy
of communism it very different from what
it is today that again is a myth that
was very prevalent and still is very
prevalent and a number of very
prodigiously and prestigious scholars
and some of our leading universities
have built their careers examining what
if
what if Lenin had lived what if Stalin
had never come to power I'm gonna finish
that off once and for all
but before I get going let's take a
quick look look let's think about Lenin
Lenin as a person for a moment think
about him as someone in his real time in
place born in 1870 in the town of bisque
in central Russia this is not someone
who came from the kind of polished
rising bourgeois world of st. Petersburg
and Moscow someone who grew up in a kind
of environment in which there was a sort
of rising sense of Russia becoming part
of what bracing Western ideas of
becoming part of a larger Europe I
talked about this in my new books I
won't go into all the detail well we
have to remember about Lenin is that he
comes from a basically rough-and-tumble
frontier town a town that sits on the
border between Russia and what had been
the Tartar Empire the Empire of
tamerlane that his grandmother in fact
was a Tartar woman he grew up in an area
of constant ethnic conflict of a kind of
latent violence sort of the Russian Wild
West and so for Lenin the world of
Enlightenment and ideas and so on is
really in a sense something that's
superimposed upon a world in which he
grew up in which his family had heritage
was based upon his father his father was
a Russian civil servant very very very
prestigious someone with very successful
he was a state inspector of schools his
mother came from a very comfortable
family the great tragedy that shattered
that family however came in 1887 when
his beloved elder brother alexei Yulin
off because that's the family name
born Vladimir Ulyanov Lenin is a
revolutionary pseudonym assumed later on
during his during his during his career
as a revolutionary and conspirator when
his elder brother Julian are
accidentally enough is found guilty of
being involved in a plot to assassinate
the Tsar and as executed destroys the
family destroys them
and for young Vladimir the experience is
a watershed in the sense that not in the
sense that he wasn't already radicalized
and we know this from evidence that he'd
already been exposed to some radical
ideas where they were Marxist or not we
don't know we don't know but he was
certainly moving in that kind of a
direction but the execution of his of
his brother proved to him in his mind
anyway that the only way in which any
way in which Russia was really gonna
change and was going to change for the
better was through violence that
violence was the answer that what his
brother and his handful of hapless
conspirators had tried to do needed to
simply be better organized and carried
out in a more in a more in a more direct
in a more in a more efficient manner and
so he becomes a revolutionary he becomes
a revolutionary becomes someone who's
going to spend almost three decades
either doing a spot of bird in Siberia
as the British would say or on the other
hand being in exile in foreign countries
and traveling around and traveling
around avoiding secret police and the
other experience other kinds of threats
including from other revolutionaries
that he was constantly exposed to and
this is one of the other things that I
want you to understand about Lenin Lenin
the Exile Lenin the man on the run is
that for him the real battle the battle
he's engaged in a daily weekly basis his
articles and his in his meetings and his
discussions and forming his band of
conspirators isn't against the Czar or
the Czarist police they turn out to be
unbelievably inept in terms of their
being able to deal with the threat that
goes with the exile
it's with his fellow revolutionaries
with the fellow radicals he's dealing
with and his deep and abiding desire to
emerge on top but this is the driving
thing for Lenin is a confidence in the
belief that he's got the answer
he knows how this is going to be done
and in the fight in the face of every
frustration in the face of every defeat
he keeps coming back because he is
convinced that he knows the answer to
what is coming and what's going to take
place which is unleashing the power of
class war I'm gonna come back to that
and come back to that when I talk about
the mist that's when it come back to the
second myth but let's go forward to
think about the first of the myths that
we have to dispel especially in the
shadow and the shadow the centenary of
the Russian of the Russian Revolution of
of October according to the old Russian
calendar actually November according to
the Gregorian calendar and this is the
myth that surrounds him as being sort of
the figurehead of the Russian Revolution
what takes place what happens here
presenting him is the great
revolutionary leader it's not a truth of
it the real revolution the real Russian
Revolution had taken place months before
months before the Russian Revolution
that Lenin leads it takes place in March
when the masses the crowds in the
capital of Russia
Petrograd have been renamed after the
outbreak of World War one because
saint-petersburg it was felt was -
German - German eyes dand so it's
renamed is Petrograd when they simply
get fed up with the whole incompetence
and the whole breakdown that had taken
place with the Czarist government trying
to mobilize for war it was a complete
disaster and for the people even living
in the capital food and the moat and the
basic goods had become scarce impossible
to find when they rise up spontaneously
there was no organization to it there
were groups who rise up to join and
follow the the masses who rise up in
order to to sort of say we're fed up
we're done with this war we're done with
this government we're done with the
incompetence we need a change and so in
March of night
19:17 a massive wave of spontaneous
revolution sweeps through the capital at
Petrograd topples the Tsar pushes it
into abdicating and creates a new
government a republican government a
republican government led by a handful
of men who were connected with the
representative body that have been set
up after the revolution of 1905 the duma
basically Russia's parliament which up
until then had basically been a
collection of figureheads
men who had been denied power by the
tsar and by his government but now in
the power vacuum step forward to take
command to hold power and to reshape
Russian a new direction to move it in a
new direction and it began the process
then of trying to create a modern
democratic Russia on the bones and the
and the ruins of the old Czarist
imperialist Russia that the set that the
First World War had shattered and
destroyed well that the commitment that
that government had in the fragile power
that fighter hold on power that it held
in in Petrograd and also in Moscow but
Russia was the kind of country in which
whoever holds power in the capital holds
power throughout the country doesn't
matter what happens elsewhere it's the
capital that counts the crowds the
streets the the riots the scenes that's
the center of action that's the deaths
center stage for power in Russia in 1917
March 1917 the government that comes to
power is committed to two things to make
a new Russia a modern democratic one
that can integrate with the West and on
the other side committed to keeping
Russia in the war against Germany and
Austria but mostly against Germany that
was there their chief chief Ally and
this was the commitment they had made as
a way to unite Russia with its Western
Democratic allies we're going to be a
fellow democracy with you and we're
going to fight against the power the
forces of authority
and tyranny embodied in the cotton
Kaiser Wilhelm's Germany well while all
this happens the German High Command is
fascinated Russia's falling into chaos
the capital in upheaval and so they
consider it they begin to consider an
idea how can we how can we help this
process forward of making Russia fall
deeper and deeper into a state of chaos
into a deeper state of disorder and then
one of the Ambassador or their
ambassador in Switzerland has an idea he
said you know I've got this guy over
here in Zurich this obscure forty-five
year old who's been writing article
after article about you know radicalism
and other kinds of things and he's been
involved with all this what if we send
him over there and get him to stir up
the crowds and get things going and
create some more sure of chaos maybe we
can even drive Russia out of the war by
spreading chaos and so a deal is struck
by which the Germans will transport
Lenin and his followers from Zurich
across what was for a Russian enemy
territory right through the heart of
Germany Austria into into neutral Sweden
and then across to and then across to to
Russia in order to stir up trouble in
Lenin it tells a lot about his character
by the way he immediately says yes I'll
do it
that his willingness to not only accept
the help from his country's enemy
Germany but also to receive money from
them I mean he was getting rigged his
bank account set up his regularly being
supplied with money for them to keep his
revolutionary cause alive in Russia says
a lot about what he believed was gonna
happen he would by any means necessary
you know that slogan right that's that's
Lenin I'm going to bring revolution I'm
gonna bring the leverage to Russia I
don't care who helps me even the hated
Germans you know the worst of the worst
from the point of view of a Marxist
standpoint even the worst of the worst
I'll accept their help on SEP their
connection and so the deal is struck and
he and his family and his followers
travel across
in what comes to be called a sealed
train it wasn't a sealed train the fact
of the matter is is the Germans just
made sure that he didn't step off the
platform and go talk to others about
rising
alright the workers rising up to to
fight against the repressors and things
like that and they drop them off and he
arrives therefore at the Finland station
in in Petrograd on April 12 1917 in
order to stir up trouble no one not even
his own followers thought he could
actually achieve anything that besides
just based clearing up trouble the
German authorities wanted to cause chaos
that's what they wanted chaos that would
in the end drive Russia into a state of
anarchy in which it could no longer
sustain the war effort
Lenin goal was very different he wanted
power and his goal was to achieve power
however it was going to happen and he
was the one person who believed he could
and through a series of strange missteps
through a combination of his own sheer
fanatical willfulness and weakness on
the part of the new fragile democratic
government that had come into power he
was able to achieve that achieve not
just power but supreme power and by
November of the 6th and 7th he's able to
achieve it he tried in July a coup was
attempted in order to topple the
government but it failed
especially when the newspapers leaked
the information about his connections
with the Germans and other Russian said
oh my god this Lenin he's a traitor he's
working for the Germans our enemies in
this war here and he has to flee for the
border and he goes into hiding in
Finland for a few months but then again
the government loses control of the
situation its hold on power is
precarious and Lenin in in in October
realizes the time is right to try again
in fact he probably would not have even
tried again if it hadn't been for the
support of one person and that's Leon
Trotsky if you if anyone is responsible
for the revolution that topples the the
Duma the government the provisional
government that held power since March
the real Russian Revolution who was Leon
Trotsky he's the one who mobilizes the
troops he's the one who mobilizes the
sailors to march
from Kronstadt naval base down to the
down to the duma palace in order to
force a change of government lenin
simply cashes in follows in the
slipstream behind what Trotsky is
achieved but he manages to hold power he
manages to grab power in the process so
the real story behind Lenin the real
star be environment Lenin is not the
father revolution but the destroyer the
Russian Revolution he's the man who
topples it through a coup a coup d'etat
at the time in which he and his
Bolshevik followers including Trotsky
and Stalin seized power from a
government which was too weak and too
feeble and we have to sort of say to and
lack the confidence to hold power in the
face of those who are willing to use
force and violence in order to grab it
now that brings us to our second myth
the second myth the second myth is about
that that that that Lenin is in some
ways a disciple of Marxism or that
Leninism is it comes to be called is an
outgrowth or an offshoot of Marxism read
a lot of the textbooks and they talk
about this no let's be clear Lenin is
heavily influenced by Marx's theory his
exposure to Marx's works have a huge
impact on him and on his thinking and
his radicalization what's interesting by
the way as I explained in the book was
interesting about this is that is that
while living in Russia is that Lenin and
even in exile in Siberia
that Lenin has very little trouble
getting hold of text by Karl Marx while
living in Czarist Russia this is one of
the strange things about this is that
the Czarist police of course were
fiercely censorious of any kind of
foreign writings especially anything
that could be viewed as subversive we're
completely focused on writings by
indigenous russian socialists in
agrarian revolutionaries this was their
focus on that so Marx completely slipped
past their radar screen gives us an idea
how completely inept the zyra's police
were in many ways that you can go ahead
and read the communist manifesto read us
copy Toliver not at all difficult to get
hold of but anything by one of the
like Chomsky or any of the other Russian
agrarian socialist revolutionaries and
someone a copy of that is found in your
in your briefcase or found in your rooms
off to Siberia you go there's no doubt
Lenin's effect very much affected by
Marx's ideas and that it plays an
important role in his thought
but his thought Lenin's approaches it
break from Marx Marx's idea what is
Marx's idea Marx's idea is that the
march of history is one leading to
dictatorship of the proletariat that the
working class will take over the means
of production and create a whole new
classless society that this is built
into the fabric of history as we would
say I suppose today that it is encoded
in the nature of history that the
working class will take over and that
they'll sort of say to themselves one
day they wake up and they'll sort of say
we're being exploited these people are
appropriating our work our labor our
value is all being taken away and
they're they're using it the capitalist
class let's get rid of them let's
overthrow them and let's take control of
our lives take control of our society
now Marx had no doubt that the
revolution that would ensue would be
violent that the revolution that ensued
would be one in which lots of people
would be killed he was hoping a lot of
capitalists would die he had no doubts
about this you read Marx's work about
you know the future revolution it's
apocalyptic he's got bodies hanging from
lampposts and these other kinds of
things clearly clearly it was something
which he foresaw with great relish in
the future but this was in the future in
his own mind
the moat the time that it would take the
way in which this would happen was that
the working class would come to realize
they've been exposed they you know
they'd read and Karl Marx they would
read Frederick Engels they would come to
understand there's position and society
that is far from being the slaves of the
capitalist production they're the real
masters they've got to take control of
the situation and that the new society
would arise but this was in the future
this would take years maybe even decades
even in the most advanced industrialized
countries because industrialization
but built a working-class Germany
Britain this is a long way off before
all this sort of thing happens it's
inevitable it's coming but it's a long
way off and the idea that it could
happen in an undisclosed country even a
country like Russia for which Marx had
enormous contempt as a country as a
society as a culture does he say about
Russian peasants he said it's like a
sack of potatoes you know each each one
each one is is is different and yet
they're all like the idea it's a country
like this which have you know just
beginning that no real industrial
revolution underway to take place the
revolutions ridiculous Lenin's view is
the opposite it's precisely at least
industrialized countries the one in
which capitalism is just beginning to
take shape here and beginning to shake
the foundations of the traditional state
and traditional institutions that's
precisely where a handful of men a
handful of dedicated men who understand
power who understand how they can seize
power in the name of the working-class
and overthrow the existing institutions
that's the society in which the
opportunity to create a dictatorship of
the proletariat is most likely the
opportunity will be there the
opportunity what we today call a failed
state failed States is where power is
waiting to be assumed by a revolutionary
elite for Lenin that was Russia Russia
was a state in a state of collapse
especially after the war broke out
especially as the mobilization for war
led to increasing breakdown in in
Russian society and government's control
over the provinces even its control over
the capital here is the moment in which
a dedicated revolutionary elite can
seize power and and and grab it and
what's the point of such an exercise is
it to create a dictatorship of the
proletariat
in Lenin's view that's the phraseology
but his view expanded far greater than
that his view was that the result would
be a massive uprising a massive uprising
which would sweep Europe and sweep the
globe as the working class and their
leadership and their elite leadership
would now rise up against the existing
status quo and generate massive class
war and that's really the end for the
end game for Lenin for Lenin it is the
unleashing of violence in all of its
forms in all of its directions even in
the name of national liberation even the
name of national determination this is
what he had in mind here's a letter that
he writes and this is 17th of October
1917 shortly before the Bolsheviks
seized power the letter he writes to his
friend Alexander slip yup snip off knock
off the least bad thing that could
happen in the short term would be the
defeat of Czar ISM in the war the
essence of our work which must be
persistent systematic and it perhaps
extremely long term he was wrong about
that it actually turned out really less
than a month is to aim for the
transformation of the war into a civil
war what will happen there's another
question as is not yet clear we must
wait for the moment to ripen and
systematically force it to ripen
violence civil war war across the board
this is what this is what his great goal
this is what his great aim is in in what
is unleashed and what's going to take
place in his mind here this is a very
different view from Marx for Marx it's
the unfolding of history that leads to
these events for Lenin it's the
unfolding of a revolutionary league
dedicated to the goal who will bring
about violence and bring about the
collapse of the existing society
what does mark say he says everything
exists deserves to be destroyed
right it's a quotation actually from the
devil from from if a star flees from
goethe's faust lenin agreed but he said
we don't have to wait for that we can do
it right now and that's where we're
going that's what we're gonna do and we
can enlist the various movements of
violence the various movements they're
involved in and and that we can take and
assume in the process here that can take
place and this include national
liberation movements around the world
not just in Europe and in colonial areas
he says in one of his one of his letters
to his friends he says to imagine that
social revolution is conceivable without
revolts by small nations in the colonies
and in Europe with all their prejudices
is to repudiate the idea of social
revolution the Bolsheviks will be very
poor revolutionaries if in the
proletariat's great war for liberation
for socialism we do not know how to
utilize every popular movement whether
it's outside or Russia or whether it's
in Ireland the Easter rebellion in 1916
in which everywhere all his fellow
Bolsheviks were appalled that this is a
terrible what are they doing he's loved
it he thought this was perfect this is
exactly the kinds of people you would
want to enlist and involved with a group
like Isis today Lenin would embrace them
this is exactly who the kind of kind of
group we need to be with people who are
creating chaos people who are creating
disorder because out of that failure the
collapse of existing since institutions
we can seize power we can grab we can
grab what others have lost the grip on
when you think about Lenin versus Marx
believe me Lenin becomes almost sort of
quaint thinker it's like a real 19th
century thinker almost antiquated in his
belief in his waiting for history to
move to move the dials of events and the
new dials of human history forward Lenin
doesn't care where history is going what
he cares about is being on the right
side of the gun and that mouths famous
motto right power comes from the barrel
of a gun
Lenin never said it but that sees the
one who believed and he's the one who
put that idea
motion and it's one which all of his
great followers especially in the world
outside of Russia especially in the
world outside of Russia will get worse
stalin less so Stalin was very
suspicious about third world
nationalists Andrey liberation movements
even Mao made him very nervous he was
not happy this Asiatic guy he was not
into it
and things like that Lenin would have
embraced Mao at once realized this is my
guy this is the kind of person I want to
be connected with and that's why by the
way one of his closest followers will
become Ho Chi Min Ho Chi Min Ho Chi Minh
who goes to the Paris Peace Conference
in 1919 right in a rented tuxedo he's
working as a waiter did you know that
his working as a waiter one of the Paris
hotels and he goes to the ghosts of the
conference and a rented tuxedo talked
about the rights of the Vietnamese
people you know and then of course he's
like pushed you know Wilson the rest
don't want to listen to this guy talk
about these things so he's deeply
disappointed he goes back to his hos
back to his his small flat and there he
picks up a year later he picks up
Lenin's one of his Lenin seminal texts
by the way which is his theses on the
National and colonial questions which is
about precisely the ability of what we
call the third world to unleash the
forces of violence that will topple not
just imperialism but will topple the
whole edifice on which booze wah
capitalism and democracy rests and he
reads them and he says this is this is
Ho Chi Minh I'm quoting her Chi Minh now
in his memoirs he says Lenin's theses
roused me to great emotion great
enthusiasm great faith and helped me to
see the problem clearly my joy was so
great that at times I was reduced to
tears alone in my room I would cry out
as though standing before a great crowd
my beloved downtrodden luckless
compatriots this is what we need this is
our road to freedom after that I put all
of my trust in Lenin and the Third
International Vietnam China North Korea
they all spring not from Stalin
not from Stalin they spring from Lenin
Lenin is the source of that laning is
the source he's the one who like Osama
bin Laden comes to see failed States as
the breeding ground for revolution the
breeding ground for class war and for
transformation and all that takes place
with that so is Lenin a disciple of Marx
in an intellectual sense in a genealogy
of ideas way yes of course there's no
denying that but Lenin's view Lenin's
view world view is not a political
philosophy it's a program for
revolutionary action
it's a program set up for translating
violence into creating destroying an old
order and creating a new order from it
now as for the nature of that new order
let's think about that for a second
let's think about in this week now we
come to our third our third topic and
that is Lenin's order what he would if
he had lived longer would have descend
into Stalin's tyranny
I think there's absolutely no doubt
about that everything you know if you
read my book and you read the steps he
took immediately after after the seizing
power in November of 1917 you come to
realize this is a man who has one thing
on his mind and that is to shed as much
blood as possible in order to wipe away
the old order in order to create a new
one which would be dominated by him and
his party elite by the Bolshevik Party
elite there's no doubt about that at all
every step of the way the creation of a
secret police the creation of the of the
original gulags the creation of the Red
Terror all of these things all of these
things bring naught from Stalin they
don't even spring from Trotsky who was
in his own way a kind of revolutionary
fanatic they spring from they spring
from Lenin and his apolar proach to
these subjects and what takes place let
me just read to you for example a
telegram you sent off to the Central
Executive Committee this is in 1918 this
is less than a year after taking power
if you want to see the real Lenin here's
the real Lenin speaking to the Central
Executive Committee of the Soviet in
Penza comrades the Kulak uprising in
your five districts
be crushed without pity for those of you
who know kulaks meant rich peasants
basically meant anyone who resisted the
revolutionary and what the Bolsheviks
were going anyone who did counted now is
a Kulak the interests of the whole
revolution demands such actions for the
final struggle with the kulaks has now
begun you must make an example of these
people one hang I mean hang publicly so
people see it at least 100 kulaks rich
bastards and known bloodsuckers too
published their names now why would he
say that so their families are also then
become targets so their families also
become targets for revolutionary revenge
three seals all of their grain and I'll
come back to that point in a second
single out for single out the hostages
per my instructions in yesterday's
telegram do all this so that for miles
around people see it all understand it
all tremble and tell themselves that we
are killing the bloodthirsty coax and
that will continue to do so and you
don't want to be a Kulak was the basic
rule with this of course unspoken reply
saying you have received and carry out
these instructions yours linen PS find
tougher people those who are carrying
out my orders aren't tough enough aren't
ruthless enough we need we need those
who are willing to do this without
hesitation so the old idea the old idea
that was there was that that I learned
when I studied Russian history in
college and so on that somehow Lenin's
death and his premature fall from power
just six years after after the after
coming coming to power in November of
1917 that somehow this opened the door
to Stalin to make things worse to create
a realm of Terror the realm of Terror
was already there the ring of Terror was
already there understood under Lenin
Stalin if anything in many ways
regularized it systematized it in a way
in which in Lenin's case had sprung from
a deep and abiding fascination with
violence a fascination with bloodshed a
fascination with the idea of a war that
would spread from Russia across
and burn through the rest of the globe
through to every country and every every
class in society through it now I want
to finish up with the three legacies the
three legacies that I see from Lenin
here I mean legacies that live on today
the legacies that we see today and that
are part of Lenin's overall overall
contribution of that's the word for it
a contribution to making the world more
more chaotic and more horrible then then
one could imagine here in fact I think
if only there's one single person who
has done that in the broadest possible
sense in the last 100 years that has to
be Lenin three three legacies the first
is the idea of the total of total
control state the total control state
and this sprang from the very first
legislation that came from the Bolshevik
a seizure of power in November and that
was legislation that put all
distribution of food within the capitol
of Petrograd within the hands of the
government nobody could get any food
unless they'd have been authorized by
the government and from Petrograd that
then spreads to Moscow to the other
cities and then to the surrounding areas
we all know the history the terrible
history that follows from all that what
Lenin understood was that if you want to
grab control of people grab control
their food right the basic lesson that
the Bolshevik Revolution put in place
from the very beginning and by the 1818
in 1919 had become standard standard
part of government practice by Lenin's
regime was it if you if you don't obey
you won't eat that's very powerful very
powerful tool especially in the country
which we have to say is a result of
World War one in which food supplies
have broken down and become very
difficult to get control get food to get
act and so the government taking control
in one sense was justified on the other
hand it was justified not in a way
to give food but to deny it to deny it
to those who didn't obey who didn't go
along who didn't become part of it part
of the system part the government and
this is an important principle which
Lenin has left on and is allowed to
continue on if you control people
physically right control their destiny
physically it's very very difficult for
them to disobey to disobey break away
from the government whether it's a
question of food where's your question
of control of their healthcare whether
it's a confessional control of their
livelihood the welfare state the welfare
state whatever else we can say about its
origins you know it's good intentions
and so on it becomes in a very short
period of time a tool a tool for control
a tool to sort of say you know you don't
want those payments to stop do you you
don't want us to cut off the supply of
health care your ability to get those
kind of so you have to go along you have
to become part of the system and what
follows through all this that's Lenin
that's Lenin the [ __ ] regime who put
that into place and set it up there the
second legacy is the total surveillance
state because you can't have total
control if you don't have if you're not
keeping track of what people are doing
every single day in every aspects of
their lives together with control over
the food supply the government control
over who gets food and who doesn't
Lenin's want to let his first steps is
to create a secret police the military
Revolutionary Committee I talked about
all this in the book by the way when it
comes out in November and then read all
the details about it is very the the
revolutionary militia that he's used to
seize power very quickly becomes a
secret police by which to enforce and
control what takes place in the country
and to make sure again in the guise of
hunting for traitors actually hunting
for dissenters anyone who does stands in
the way other government stands in the
way of the regime that's also part of it
too that the and and the growth of this
total surveillance state with its secret
police with its use of informants I mean
you look at the history of not just the
Soviet Union but also everywhere where
the Soviets went and the Iron Curtain
the conversion of a substantial part of
the population to becoming informants to
the police right which is a way it's a
double it's it's a double win if you're
a totalitarian it's a double win because
in the one hand you get to find out
everything that's happening because
people are constantly informing you on
your neighbor or your family members and
so on what they're doing that goes
against the the views of the the regime
right what they're supposed to believe
but it also soothes see those the seeds
of a distrust that runs and corrupts the
whole fabric of society because you
never know who you're sitting with in a
cafe who you're sitting with on a train
who you're sitting with and you're
you're talking with on Facebook who's
not a police spy right you know no you
don't know and so you hold it in you
don't say what you really think you toe
the line you set it up to toe the line
and in a country like for example now in
Russia this has improved Putin's Russia
and it's reached its culmination in the
whole total surveillance system that the
regime is set up called sort of Moe
didn't we know about Sorum I wrote an
article about a year and a half ago and
commentary about it sorum is the the
successors to the KGB the FSB a creator
system in which they are able to not
only find out everything that you're
saying on the internet and watching on
the internet and everything that you're
everyone you're talking to on the
telephone or through social media and
everything that you're involved with a
daily basis and so on but they're able
to take that information and integrate
it integrate it with the surveillance
cameras that are set up all across the
capital all across Russia to monitor
parking lots and workplaces and subways
and everything else so it becomes
possible to keep track of what you're
doing and what you're doing every single
moment of the day and if you happen to
sort of fall within the purview of the
government is being sort of suspicious
character which is actually not that
difficult in a regime like Putin's
Russia or President Xi's China and so on
you are under surveillance every single
second
and we'll keep track of it doesn't mean
you're in big trouble right doesn't mean
you're gonna be arrested any second but
it does mean that they know what you're
up to and then sometimes even know what
you're up to before you do right right
and that's a total surveillance state
that's your real dream if you want to be
a secret chief of secret police which I
hope none of you do but that's the most
important role of all is to have that
power to know what others are going to
do before they do because of the total
surveillance network the total
surveillance system then created and
then the third one this is where I'm
going to finish up the third legacy is
the total information state we call it
propaganda but that's not even touching
the real issue here the total
information state that there is only one
view point allowed on every issue in
every question and the regime and all
the power of the state is there to
reinforce it and to enforce that one
single view it's interesting when the
Soviets came in when the Soviets came
into the Iron Curtain countries after
the collapse of the Nazis right at the
end of World War two what was the first
thing that they did well the bus they
brought the secret police no question
but the second thing that they did was
they brought their radio broadcasts and
radio network in personnel and and
personnel to set up pro-soviet radio
networks in all those countries Hungary
Poland Czechoslovakia Romania you name
it because they knew who controls the
information controls power to broadcast
constantly a pro-soviet view a
pro-soviet worldview to everyone there
who had drowned out every other point of
view every other view about issues about
life about existence itself and of
course when you've got the secret police
calling out everybody else who does have
that alternate view this becomes very
easy to do to create such a single
monolithic view of the view of life one
dictated by the party what comes to be
called the party line the party line but
the party line is more than just
something you support in public it's
something in which there's no
alternative
there's no alternative and it's a public
view which is in a sense reinforced by
not just by describing things but
scribing things that haven't happened
right disinformation this is
disinformation as we call we've run into
that now with Putin's Russia they're
masters of this but the Masters of it
because they learned it from the Soviet
regime xavi regime was built upon
disinformation the the very the very
cool that Lenin carried out as explained
in the book was a coup not against the
government was to protect the Russian
people from the government the idea was
that they were about to arrest Lenin and
hand over power to the two to the
bourgeois and so on and Lenin his group
had to act had to act to prevent
something really terrible happening
disinformation it goes back to the very
origins of the regime it extends all the
way through Stalin all the way through
the Cold War and extends down to extends
down down to to today's today's Putin
but what's important to remember when we
talk about disinformation and about
Putin and his Facebook antics which are
very serious by the way don't
misunderstand they're very serious
because I Hudson Institute we've done a
lot of work with a big data analytics
company and you wouldn't believe the
tens of thousands of Russian trolls who
were interfering with the election it's
no myth it's no myth but bear in mind
that disinformation and political
correctness are two sides of the same
coin
the goal is to create one single view of
the world from which dissent is not
possible in which dissent is in fact in
fact dangerous it's racist it's white
supremacists it's whatever else that
comes with it it's direct with it here
and in which freedom is finally in the
end what the freedom is left is the
freedom to agree with the consensus the
freedom to agree with that one single
view that takes place here now this is
what I find rather scary about the whole
situation is that Lenin's legacy which
has come to us via the new left and
through
ooh tenured radicals it's a great title
for a book by the way someone should
write such a book sometime is Roger
Kimball here is he in the room by any
chance that that that Lenin's legacy
here has come now to take fruit and to
bear fruit in today's colleges and
universities with the notable exception
of Hillsdale of course and a few others
and we see it we see it in sub anyways
with the emphasis on the PC the emphasis
upon the idea that language the language
of those who who descent from the one
view right the one accepted view
constitutes violence and therefore it
has to be responded to with violence
it's very Lenin is straight out of Lenin
it's exactly the approach that Lenin
took to these kinds of things together
with which I have noticed over the last
decade has been an increasingly
revisionist view of communism itself a
view that really communism when we look
at it in the longest circle of you
listen to really that bad
surely no worse than capitalism right
probably better in some ways because
after all its intentions were better it
wanted to you know make people's lives
better and make them more equal and
things like this books like antonio
negret 'is empire which was a
best-seller came out just before 9/11 as
a matter of fact but its impact is there
its impact is palpable these kinds of
books in this approach to it and this is
what we have to remember it constantly
remind ourselves is that what Lenin when
you look at linen look at what his life
in his writings and so on what you see
is the raw truth about communism if I
may paraphrase a certain president in
his speech at the UN very recently what
we see we look at a country like North
Korea it's not the failure to implement
Koppel communism
it's the implement it's the faithful
implementation of communism the fire end
of it here and it's important for us all
of us here to keep bear that in mind and
to look at the young people around you
right look at them it's the fruit of a
generation
but remember that each one of them for
all of them they're under the age of 30
anyway the fall the Berlin Wall its
history they've no memory it's something
that happened long ago in their minds
from their perspective here very
important to bear that in mind about
this for we all have been Berlin Wall
was the end of a process it was the end
of a finish it was a closure on a
certain historical era and a historical
conflict but for them it's a part of
history not much more than that and if
we don't make explain the context to
them it will fade into insignificance in
the process you know there's a Anne
Applebaum is one is a historian and some
of you may know her she's written books
on gulag she's written books on Iron
Curtain
she has a new book she's recently
published on Stalin's Great Famine
really depressing subjects to talk about
and discuss but at a conference wants
someone asked her they said to Ann she
said you know you work on all this stuff
you write all these books is it because
you're worried that someday this will
happen again and she said no she said
because I know it will happen again and
it seems to me that in the end and one
of the reasons I wrote this book is in
and the responsibility every one of us
in this room sitting here carries is to
make sure that her protection never
comes true I'm done thank you
now I'm told that the young people with
the Barca phones are gonna find the ones
asking questions so I can't play
favorites so I'm just gonna sit here and
let them pick out the ones who who have
questions but I see somebody's arm way
up in the back I can't resist Thank You
dr. Herman please raise your hand and a
microphone will be brought to you what
are your comments about the recent
revelation about the Communists
graduating from West Point well we all
have we all have our histories right I
mean you look nude on it you don't know
what my history was due oh my I I
haven't told them he told many people
about this but when I was in fourth
grade I was passing out copies of the
communist manifesto to my fellow
students and Jefferson School in Stevens
Point Wisconsin I was a thorough radical
I grew up in a very left-left family so
I know how these histories go and what
takes place I think though and don't
forget I've on the other side of us here
in the biography of Joseph McCarthy
right which was I think a lot of people
felt maybe too sympathetic to McCarthy
in terms of his views about issues about
loyalty right the questions of loyalty
to one's country the question about what
communism represents as an ideology but
also as a as a as the antithesis
antithesis for what America stands for
and what it represents and I think we've
slid very much very much in the wrong
direction with regard to that and
there's a kind of tolerance that
communism you know it's a period it's
sudden it's a period kids go through and
things like that or what history has
gone through and we're over it we're not
we are not compared to the threat of neo
communism I think the threat of neo
Nazism that you know that bedevils the
media today is minimal compared to the
threat of neo communism because it it
comes in so many pervasive ways it comes
in so many pervasive ways in the way in
which in a way in which extremist
ideologies on the right
in this country simply cannot and cannot
gain purchase here so you know when
you're when you're 11 years old handing
out copies of Communist Manifesto I
think you can forgive that can't you
you can forget but at West Point I don't
think it's a great you know I think it's
a great thing well solid where does Saul
Alinsky fit into the into the framework
well I mentioned the new left and of
course I was thinking not only of Saul
Alinsky but also of the whole cohort who
came and who who came to came of age in
the 1960s and who translated many of the
Leninist pro-russia Helena's program
into a program for transforming America
and if they couldn't do it through
revolution on the streets then they
would do it through revolution in
academia what comes to be called the
long march through the institution's
yeah but well I think what's important
again from an historical genealogy of
ideas point of view is that who is Saul
Alinsky's hero who is his Roma its Lenin
it's not Stalin the new left despised
stone they hated the old line communists
who had you know follow the Stalinist
line through the nazi-soviet pact and
even you know adhere to it after
Khrushchev secret speech talking about
all the terrible things that Stalin had
done and had carried out here as well
and so we overlooked the fact that Lenin
Lenin is the culprit here he's he's the
hateful that awful as Stalin is Lenin's
impact I think is more global frankly
and more important in terms of in terms
of where we are and what has happened
over the last hundred years his
influences this is more far-reaching and
at least as destructive that answer your
question
I think good okay thank you for coming
to you to give us a great lecture my
name is Doyle and my question is that
had the Communists taken the approach of
Marx in terms of running history unfold
in implementing communism do you think
they would have ever been successful
still how do you think they would still
have ever been successful in
implementing implementing the dangerous
ideology it's an interesting kind of at
what if well I think they would have
been a very at a very interesting
discussion group you know up through the
1920s and 1930s look the turn that Lenin
took was not just his alone there was
there was in Russia a number of other
Marxist thinkers who likewise the
argument was twofold
one was Marx was wrong Russia is much
more industrialized than he ever us than
he ever realized
and in fact Lenin's first important
published work which is really his only
work of economic analysis is a study of
the growing industrialization of Russia
which really sort of says hey we
actually are becoming a blues-rock
capitalist country therefore by Marx's
own standards we should be right for
revolution and ready to go and that was
a widely accepted view among other
Russian Marxist at the time I mean if
you're gonna be a Marxist you want to be
revolutionary you don't want to be sort
of saying well well get-get back to me
in 50 years and most her to see what's
gonna happen right well we're ready for
revolution yet that's not that's not how
you justify what you're doing but but
what Lenin did was to was to take the
next move and that was is that is that
we don't have to wait for a critical
mass of working class that once you've
got a Revell professional revolutionary
elite who know how to take power and
know how to manipulate power then the
working class will come along and if a
working class doesn't that's too bad for
them we're doing it for them and if they
don't appreciate it then then it's a
bullet in the head and this is of course
what what in fact happened to them in
the process so the waiting waiting for
Marx is waiting for Marx waiting for
godot the
you know these are processes that extend
out far being on the horizon and
European socialism had taken that turn
under Edward Bernstein you know we'll
take it a slow we'll take a slow
approach to transformation of Europe
into socialism right that was Edward
Bernstein it's one that Lenin excoriated
it's one that he is despised than in
many ways you could argue that his
radical activist position that I talked
about here was in direct opposition to
the Bernstein incrementalist socialist
approach that the other European
socialist parties have taken it becomes
the the break the break that comes
between your mainstream socialist
parties and then the communist parties
that develop under the under the third
international what else giving what
you've told us why the antipathy between
Lenin and Stalin especially after that
second stroke where he says what are we
do don't make him hit well this is this
is a question that requires a tiny
little bit of background for those who
aren't familiar with the Lenin Stalin
dynamic Stalin of course was a was a
loyal follower from early days of the
revolution who began to gain more and
more power as head of the head of the
party in assuming war more bureaucratic
control over the party especially after
Lenin's the separate his assassination
attempt and then his first stroke in in
in 1922 I think a lot of his antipathy
ran to Stalin had less to do with where
where Stalin was going to take the party
and more about the way in which he felt
that Stalin's control was one dedicated
not towards advancing revolution but
advancing Stalin
and I think what he saw in Stalin was
someone who was not up to the real job
that Lenin wanted which was the ongoing
spread of the revolution out beyond the
soap beyond Soviet borders Stalin in the
end becomes after all the man who
embraces socialism in one country and
who curtailed the if I say the sort of
the the zeal with which Lenin saw the
war spreading the way in which class
violence and war would spread across
Europe and Stalin was somebody who
instinctively repelled the rebelled
against that view his view is the view
of a bureaucrat from a desk it's not
from a revolutionary with a rifle he's
not Che Guevara in other words Che
Guevara is the kind of person that Lenin
would have wanted
Trotsky would have been would have been
a good pick from his point of view I
think would have been the ideal pick
with it but Stalin represented the
victory of bureaucracy over charisma in
his mind and this is not the way that
that not the future of path for the
revolution from Lenin's
from Lenin's mind and in many ways it
was true and as I mentioned the embrace
of revolution in the third world
Stalin stays away from that kind of
thing Stalin develops more normal
relations and looks to normal relations
with West with the Europe for example in
Western Europe and sort of brings Russia
back into the I won't say a community of
nations that's absurd but makes
establishes more sort of normal
relations with the other parts other
great powers of Europe here turns away
from the third world the man who does
who picks that up of course is
Khrushchev Chris Jeff is the one who
then realizes there's in the
post-colonial world the post imperialist
world there's all these opportunities to
spread net it through national
liberation movements to spread the the
power of of the Soviet Union through the
gospel of communism and so he revise
including places like Cuba yeah
Lenin would be very much in favor of
that kind of an approach Stalin stated
steers clear from that kind of thing so
Stalin I think in many ways you can sort
of say is too much of a moderate
for from Lennon's point of view if you
can believe that if you can believe that
we now have time for one more question
hi my name is Conrad when I was born was
pretty much when the wall was going down
and I was fortunate enough when I was
younger to live in Berlin and there's a
really fascinating history in that city
I think anyone that's been there you can
see the scars of what socialism did
there but in our contemporaries you know
kids the people my age if you go to
Berlin you know they can be standing
next to shrapnel scars from World War
two and they have this deep antipathy
towards anything has to do with
communism like they don't care or
they're even Pro communists or in some
way just reliving the entire revolution
again and one of the things that I fear
is like that happening in America and I
think that's something everyone here
probably shares so as someone who's
younger and who's dealing with
contemporaries who are falling back into
these ideas how would you suggest that
we could go about inoculating ourselves
and our generation from these ideas
taking hold again well no I'm not gonna
sort of say read my book I think that to
be that's too self-serving I'm not gonna
go quite that far although that's
actually probably a good idea that's
probably good but I think also simply
having a true and frank accounting of
what takes place you know the with the
Holocaust right the expressions never
forget and we don't forget we're
constantly reminded we're constantly
looking at and thinking about what
happened the human cost the ideologies
that underlay it right and the kinds of
crimes but also the kinds of
personalities who are drawn to that
terrible terrible episode in history and
I think we need to keep doing that with
with Soviet Union as well and I think
one of the ways in which to do it I just
put my finger on as they think about it
is the issue of personalities focus on
style and focus on Lenin focus on
Trotsky who also gets a pass because you
know he ends up becoming you know
Stalin's great nemesis and leads a whole
series of Investigations in committees
challenging the truth the
in the Moscow trials which he was right
to do in his supporters her right to do
but trustees know better than the other
two I mean he's even in some ways you
could say worse here or the men who
surrounded who and who worked with
Stalin you know all of these figures who
are you know Kaganovich and Virage Salaf
and bay area and Molotov and so on
what's important to realize is and this
is sometimes obscured in the way in
which we read about them in the history
books but needs to be emphasized these
guys never lost the faith one of the
reasons they were willing to commit the
crimes that they did was because they
believed that this was the way in which
they were going to create a better
society a better society the way Marx
had pointed the direction the way Lenin
had pointed the direction here these
were leftists in power we have to always
remember about these men in been left us
in power with absolute power and that
they exercised in the name of an
ideology not just personal power not
just for the sake of the greater Russia
or whatever kinds of other sorts of
motivations or that we can late lay out
lay at their feet that the the
ideological dimension to what the Soviet
Union did even under Stalin here must
never be forgotten must be constantly
emphasized here so that those who
venture into that territory just as we
do with neo-nazis right you see the
swastika you know exactly there's a
history behind that there's an ideology
behind that likewise with the hammer and
sickle huh don't you think well it was a
hammer and sickle there should be a
similar moral equivalence in the minds
of those who are engaged in and that I
think is a powerful powerful pedagogical
mission that means to be embarked on in
thinking about these events and where
they have taken in the last taken us all
in the last 100 years and the price
we've all paid for it you guys have been
great thank you so much
[Applause]